let's say you have your full budget what
happens
oh I got the whole budget huh at one
time all in the account oh
somebody believes in it maybe who knows
maybe they well then then we then we
essentially start how we start the
process we're officially in
pre-production we walk down to whatever
that date is that we were planning on
that we got them to do in the first
place off of a production date that we
were with some imaginary date that we
put out in the sky now that imaginary
date's not imaginary
yeah especially if you've done some
pre-work and you've had a conversation
or maybe you've had actually gotten to
Idris Elba somehow or
so now you've got Idris Elba interested
in the project and now you actually have
the money so now it's like okay maybe
it's a race to address Elvis schedule
when is he available
or if Idris elbus becomes not available
who can we replace with that because it
starts to be more than likely we be
hinged our package with a movie like
this on who the star is going to be so
if we don't get necessary to start that
might be another reason why we can't
spend the money
like they can put that as a it has to be
and just elbow are a star that we agree
to
in the contract I can easily say that
so that'll give you that would give you
a green light but only a green light if
you can get that person and you maybe
only have a window of a certain amount
of time and can you make it
you're already under the gun and you
just got the money
or maybe this hotel is going to be
demolished that we're going to get to
shoot in for really cheap because
they're going to demolish it anyway so
we just rented it and we can still stay
in it so we can save money on that it
was in the production plan
so if we don't make it to that then now
we're gonna have to pay for it someplace
or build a set kind of blow your budget
up again
that's why you always have a 10
contingency on five million dollars it's
actually so it would be a five point
what 5.5
you actually really have a fight you
present at 5.5 million dollar budget you
don't present a five million dollar
budget
10 contingency on a budget that size
should always have a contingency on
everything but uh a lot of us don't
oh the contingency goes away it's like
I'm gonna make it no contingency the
contingency becomes your wallet
credit cards your credit cards your
family
okay just don't do car loans
oh don't don't do yours yeah don't cut
down don't do that check advance or the
cargo and things don't do that you got
this full budget it's 5 million for the
internal Butler uh how much toward
pre-production how much for production
how much sword post and then
distribution well let's say we've
already got the script and let's say I
wrote the script so screenwriter is
getting a standard wga whatever that is
for that like 100 and something thousand
dollars so that's already gone
uh uh so you own it out right
um so then you've got your copyright
chain and your lawyer you need you spend
you know you unless you have a lawyers
internally in your team so then maybe
you can get them to waive that for
points so maybe you've gotta you know 10
it's generally ten thousand dollars for
that if you're then any investor setting
up investor paperwork that could be
another ten thousand dollars too by the
way
um if you're doing all your paperwork
appropriately and having lawyers do them
if you're getting packages and things
and you make them then a member of your
team then you get all that stuff and you
don't have to worry about any of it and
you just give them points
then you've got the uh then the so
that's your pre-production money
essentially
um you know then you've got to get then
you well your pre-pre-production money
now your actual pre-production monies
are casting
right uh securing your locations
um having a so at that budget level I'm
going to bring in a production manager
um we will hire a DGA protector or make
me a DGA director because of that which
means you'll have a production
management team
which means you'll probably have to
figure out what that schedule is to
bring that out personally I wouldn't
want to shoot that size of a movie that
let's say we're doing a six-week shoot
we went at least six months of prep
so I'm probably from that date of
getting the money would probably be
about eight months out before we Shot
the movie unless there was some reason
that we had to because of Idris Elba
so then probably like I said before I'd
say 2.5 is into
in the actual physical production
uh and then probably another maybe and
we made a deal with Idris and we went
with a smaller cast so maybe we only now
have to give 1.5 to Casting
and gave interest some back end on the
movie and then we took you know and then
maybe now we've got
another 100 000 left towards you know
final you know marketing prints bubble
whatever's required to deliver the movie
for final end and Market it yourself
uh and then obviously if you're gonna
self-distribute then maybe you do a and
should build in
510 grand for
shooting you know doing a theatrical run
on your own even if you don't get one
bring up bring your status up and give
you a better deal on your thing or just
do a festival runs you gotta hit
yourself but you'll probably get in some
festivals
so you need some money for that five ten
thousand dollars at least
a hundred thousands a dream uh maybe
five ten thousand dollars you can do
that
so that's you know that's how it
allocated overall
and if you had to tighten the budget the
production budget
keeping in the main the main actor how
are you taking out ancillary characters
or whittling down locations
dwelling down locations or maybe it's
some special toys or bringing bangs that
I've got now because of the siege
whether whether hunting them after them
maybe I wanted to do some kind of flying
thing and now I have to do something
more simple you know maybe it's just a
steady game thing through the forest and
not a you know a five drone
interlocking
Steadicam five steady cam blocked off
Five camera you know now it's only you
know you've got to do it with you know a
drone and one camera
okay so you don't get that or you know
you're not going to be able to the
character like you you're still going to
get the the the the love interests who
needs to be another name
you know and that whatever type of Zone
because that way you can draw because I
think we can kind of slip this into the
romantic comedy romantic romantic drama
thing with that love story so I think
you can draw like a a stronger female
audience with that storyline so you need
to have a strong
female actress in that to draw to signal
that to them to want to come so that
would be word so you gotta have that one
but then you know maybe that's where
you're not getting it so maybe there's
some new people in some of these other
parts which I think would be fine for
that type of movie
could you have a younger unknown I mean
I hate to suggest that but could you
have a younger Unknown actress
or actor Yeah well yeah I mean I prefer
like for the lead for that one parking
it could turn out to be a younger it
could be the next city that we put in
that part you know so it could be that
yes absolutely that would then but then
you you yes you're lowering your budget
and you're lowering your scope and
you're lowering your chances again now
into festivals and your mark you know
some of those things that you're you're
hinging on selling you're now taking
away
sure and what if in the beginning Idris
Elba is you're only hearing the family's
voices and you see his reaction so
you're you're cut you're just getting
maybe voice over from people and trying
to cut out some of them so you can just
really see that he is very internal
maybe he doesn't even really see people
that much because he's so in this world
I don't know just just ways to just take
away some of the yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't necessarily be hard to say just
us just sitting here in our in our kind
of broad Studio world that we've created
but yeah I mean there's definitely like
I'm saying there's definitely ways to
look at compromising like cutting down
scope maybe changing the you know maybe
that how long you're shooting for
because I've already got it down in six
weeks you know which you know a month is
shorter but you know and but again it's
a little tight it's more like a TV movie
uh you know maybe maybe you get five
weeks out of that maybe I just lose one
you know maybe I lose a little rehearsal
maybe to get him to donate some
rehearsal make him a producer he'll do
whatever maybe he'll drop his feet
you know if he's producing then he's
more likely to drop his feet because
he's getting a producing fee anyway he
can waive his fee by the way
she really believes in the movie